elles sont seulement une petite dizaine
sur les vignobles du centre de la france
duty free jim johnson kristin 25 ans
passionné par la vinification et le
travail dans ces îles du sancerrois
saison galets bourges jeune âge qui
consiste à poser devant l'objectif est
au bout du pied et ensuite il ya la
collage c'est à dire qu'on relève les
rameaux qui sont enfin le nom durant
avec ses deux fils releveurs et en fait
on les attache avec une agrafe de
manière parce que j'ai très bien le ca
devrait pas représenter pour que le
raisin kupper enfin le maximum de
l'ensoleillement pour qu'il puisse
mourir par la suite comme il faut pour
qu'il y ait une bonne maturité en fait
christine a repris il ya deux ans
l'exploitation de son père après
plusieurs années d'études d'oenologie et
de viticulture à beaune puis à bordeaux
lagging s'est imposé à elle tout comme
elle a dû s'imposer dans ce milieu
d'hommes je pense qu'ils ont peur qu'on
leur prenne leur place alors qu'en fait
on cherche pas à prendre leur place on
cherche à se faire une place plus tôt il
faut peut-être même faire plus d'efforts
que qu'un jeune garçon qui s'installe
parce qu'en fait tout le monde regarde
un anr en dix ans cavayère eu la même
obstination et même pack chez viviane
elle voudra en amène tout salon et c'est
sur le tas qu'elle a appris le métier
avec son grand père tout petit mon mais
mon grand père m'emmenait déjà dans ma
vie dans les villes donc et c'est lui
qui m'a un petit peu habitué à ce métier
et puis bon ben c'est comme ça c'est
venu et puis on avoue de vie continue et
je vignoble vivienne exploite seul
aragon heavy gestion d'une station mise
en bouteille et cette diversité qu'elle
aime tout comme les contacts d'accidents
souvent etc selon les bienveillants
quand on commence alors quelque peu du
métier et il pose plus de questions ils
sont un peu plus surpris ils prennent un
peu plus attentionné aussi et peut-être
qu'ils illustrent mieux leurs yeux c'est
pas comme leurs collègues vignerons
viviane et christine attendent
maintenant la floraison et les vendanges
elles savent que le produit de leur
travail sera jugé avec encore plus
d'exigence